salve ragazzi allora devo spiegare una
cosa questo gioco dovrebbe essere quanto
serio perché devi salvare la vita a
donald trump non vi sto prendendo per il
culo hanno fatto un gioco dove di
salvare la vicina donald trump
noi non ho capito il perché lasciamo
perdere il fatto che c'è un quadro dove
c'è donald trump che si si masturba i
capezzoli non è tanto per quello era
perché presidente e ho già via no ma
come fermi non era preparato
psicologicamente cazzo allora move vs di
slow motion è lama d'acqua con la donald
trump
perché c'è un mirino nel petto usavo
fare io devo buttarmi su donald trump
per salvargli la vita va bene secondo
voi danno un bel film sera in tv scusate
sono arrivato in ritardo alla festa
mi dispiace infatti capire un attimo
intanto ringrazio quanti problemi se ti
partiamo rifacciamo tutto devo salvare
donald trump tasto destro slow motion
salta veloce cela pozzo è ancora vivo
stavo scherza neanche volato il
parrucchino raia ticino trump si svegli
ecco non mi sa che sono messo peggio io
difatti capire come lo prendo preso sono
forte bene l'ho salvato è suo zio bravo
donald dobbiamo farci fumerà come
contento che i capelli ciao zio
ok non ho ed il al di là il pubblico
gygera di si giri signor trump si giri
no non così si giri verso il pubblico il
pubblico perfetto perfetto no se ancora
storto va bene proviamo alla prossima
scena ragazza quindi sempre più
difficile adesso lo è ma è un attimo
adesso devo scrivere pure le sedie ci
mancava solo questo guarda ma chi cazzo
è chi classi giochi ma c'è qualcuno che
si è messo veramente lì a programmare st
merce poi un'altra domanda
il cecchino aveva solo un proiettile e
poi mi scusi signor tra no questa non
vuole veramente non volevo ma sarà
sempre più di mi dimentico che se non lo
salvo subito cielo nel culo ma io posso
intercettare tipo il proiettile
preso lo deviato ce l'ho fatta e vabbè
sono immortale ma come faccio adesso per
impiego signor trump ha visto che bravo
cos'è un nuovo passo di danza signor
trump no no queste sono cose sporche
signor trap non possiamo farlo in
pubblico perché si sta masturbando sul
mio ginocchio signor trump vabbè non fa
niente andiamo avanti ragazze io voglio
capire pian piano un attimo porca eva
prè chiude all
devo rompere il muro va bene mi chiamerà
rallenti e bellissimo reja thor cacciare
macero quanto difficile bellissima la
spaccata in volo bellissima ricca questo
è il gioco dei se non è il gioco del
secolo questo non lo so io comunque non
lo sto salvando regalo sto riuscendo
ma perché sei tutto storto ma almeno
vola dritto cacciami stesso riuscissi a
saltare un po più lento o 4 che non puoi
spostarlo dalla testa invece che la
madonna quanto sei storto senza neanche
rallenti non so è che dove sono finito
mi è sparito il personaggio press 2 pure
trend e charter va bene a perché a
capitoli questa merda va bene questo e
dove tutto ha avuto inizio questa stanza
che prima non ho visto bene
vabbè comunque io vedo solo cos'è sta
roba rampini stupia chat e professional
wrestling a devo atterrare su torna al
vetro ma cos'è centro pieno ennis demis
jonsi madonna l'ho preso
cavaleri signor trump perché tutto ad un
tratto è diventato un simpson gesta gen
salve come sei vestito zio siete dei
killer
lasciatemi andare vi prego jump spacebar
più d'hiv barcaccia traiano mancato per
un millimetro ragazzi sono un wrestler
mancato c'è un fenomeno ci siamo ci
siamo siamo preso niente spaccato tutta
la faccia bene grazie a tutti grave
adesso la [ __ ] i miei piedi gran madonna
che scarpe 60 bene adesso ma posso fare
tipo questo mi piace lo coltivo
cosa sta facendo certo con quale fisica
attenzione
dove vai fratte dove vai braccio perché
ogni tanto cambia direzione come se
niente fosse
ma chi è che le pa fortissimo eh vabbè
adesso che le scale bilancio dalla dalla
terza scala ci provo sono un fenomeno
non so quale bressler avrebbe saputo far
di meglio ragazzi ve lo giuro perfetto
no devi saltare usa la scala zio no
vabbè passiamo dall'altro lato
ok no ci sono svenuto per niente ma non
ci arrivo lega ma come cazzo volete che
ci arrivi non ci posso credere
e vabbè zio stai calmo però perfetto ci
abbiamo fatto importante è odio lelli e
lina sel come si chiamava sta roba
posso entrare dentro senza che minchi
tutto per favore posso entrare dentro
tipo di testa non era esattamente quello
che volevo fare ma va bene e va beh io
quanti problemi ci fa o ci prova è mica
fratte dove vuoi andare su saturno
le città che sia una bella [ __ ] vedi
comincia la divisione di beni che
funziona non ci posso credere che in
effetti considerando solo gli slip
potrebbe essere una bella [ __ ] finito
alterniamo andiamo a fare il salvataggio
di vita e poi torniamo al wrestling solo
per vedere che cosa succede cos'è sta
roba santo perché cadono i soldi posso
prendermi le banconote così per tutti
vabbè niente stavo scherzando salta
salta frate perfetto naderi colpirlo
però chi ha potuto solo inutile come
guardia del corpo perfetto salvo io ho
salvato anche i soldi signor trump è
visto che bravo la statua non ce l'ho
fatta mi dispiace mi scusi cos'è sta
roba
perché ma cosa avrei anche scendere le
scale che problemi non ci arriverò mai
nella vita dell'universo però vabbè
alzati lanza piazza di space make it
veramente signor trump quasi urge una
promozione qui è una guardia ma guardi
non ci posso credere mai mi scusi non
volevo giuro era solo per dare
spettacolo doveva signor trap è una
bomba signor travestì ha detto eh vabbè
io ci ho provato però è una bomba come
faccio a salvarlo da una bomba signor
trap
mi chiamo calciato sopra la bomba
perfetta se riuscisse a calciare questa
maledetta bomba prima che arrivi si
possano sposta l'ho già fatta ce l'ho
fatta fermi niente stavo scherzando che
è rimasto schiacciato dai suoi stessi
soldi maledetto veri affari miliardi
cazzo lo tolgo che è impossibile studi
d'artista ma che cazzo fai non ti ci
mette anche tu ti prego ok perché
braglia è salvo e salvo sia tra privacy
o tra pro che cade si va beh io gliel'ho
detto ramp vive non è vero ma sei caduto
è morto quanto ai vecchia sa notizia
vabbè dai non fa niente ragazzi facciamo
l'ultimo si può passare senza perfetto
bravo dove devo andare
ma dov'è addietro i soldi mi chiama non
ci arrivò mai nella vita
e invece va bene sono morto in compenso
perché non mi sto più alzando ma ok
bastava di ce ne sono perché continua a
cascare sui soldi big money back
continui a cascare dalle scale zio che
problema frate dai cazzo alzati che c'è
troppo e che ha bisogno di te ma dai zio
non ci posso credere
niente continua a cadere come un ameba
intanto trump è morto e grazie al cazzo
ok forse se tiro testate al muro mi alzo
prima no s'è tirato è stato al muro
rimango trama hanno invece si toglilo
non ha preso papa affanculo dai down per
un millimetro 0re che se vado piano le
scendo le scale
no niente neanche andando via già
proprio dei problemi con le scale sto
fratello zio are caccia la eva lercia
niente non ce la faccio dire che non ho
parole non ho parole
quanti problemi toglilo porca [ __ ] ad
alzate alzate barcaccia eva aveva
avvenuto il parrucchino
ok minchia che tuffo di lato perfetto
toglilo toglilo toglilo toglilo perfetto
ce l'ho fatta ci ho messo un ora per
farsela cosa però va bene oddio ti
ringrazio la gabba basta ecco la mia
paga 12 giorni di lavoro duro dove la
gente e tenta di uccidere trump ma io
riesco incredibilmente salvare la
situazione dato sono un alcolizzato
ragazzi non voglio continuare più perchè
ho paura di quello che può succedere
santo di dio e fatemi provare solo uno
solo per curiosità re che a corpo che è
vabbè pure chi è che gli ammessi barilli
quanti problemi che che ha messo in bari
va beh ma siete stronzi al perfetto
perfetto perfetto salva lo zio salvalo
ok ok questo volevo dall'inizio questo
volevo porca eva ra difficile perché ci
sta gente in una gabbia che problemi
fatto crollare la gabbia siete liberi
signori volate c'erano trump voli stanno
scherzando ragazzi basta
spero che vi sia piaciuto spero abbia
imparato come salvare la vita un
presidente in caso di necessità
questo tutorial prendetelo alla lettera
mi raccomando quindi ragazzi con credo
che l'episodio sul mister president
spero che mi sia piaciuto e come al
solito giunge al momento è un mi piace
anche la pace di facebook e co minimi la
trascrizione censiti siete cv diavolo
prossimo vinto dai ragazzi